You see this one little candle right
here? This candle is going to change
everything you know about entering and
exiting trades. And I'm going to break
it down in this video. Let's get right
into it. What's going on guys? Mr. Zinc
here. In today's video, I'm going to
teach you exactly how you should be
entering and exiting
trades. The whole basis of this concept
is that you are always waiting for a
retest before you enter. Now, if you do
not get a retest, you don't have a
trade. That trade does not fit into your
trading model. Therefore, you forego it
and you wait for that retest. I made the
mistake this morning, uh, today is June
2nd, 2025. I made the mistake this
morning of entering a trade prior to it
retesting my trading model. What ended
up happening was I took a $400 loss.
$460 loss to be exact. And I corrected
that by actually waiting for the retest
and then capitalizing on that
expansion. Going back to the sockel
chart from the beginning of the video,
this one little candle is exactly the
retest that you were waiting for. As you
can see on this chart, we have a pretty
bullish pattern. We have a bullish
penant forming. We're making higher lows
as we're going to equal highs, waiting
for price to break out of this
resistance, in which case it did at
1255. And we can see that the candle
that broke was a strong green candle.
Now, you can enter right on that candle.
That's fine. Nothing wrong with that.
But you can always, well, almost always
get a better entry if you just wait for
the
retest. And that's the whole concept.
You need to deploy patience in order to
avoid those losses where you get out for
a loss and then the trade ends up
running. This retest, this is again a
beautiful pattern. We have a a bullish
pennant
forming. This retest is as picture
perfect as it gets. You have a beautiful
fivem minute retest down to the level
that you broke after waiting for three
hours and then you have a continuation
off of that level. The same concept is
present with every single trading model.
Doesn't matter what it is.
Continuations, reversals, swing points,
whatever you trade, there is always
going to be a retest. And the reason
there's always a retest is that's big
money stepping in to sweep liquidity,
sweep the small guys out, get the best
entry as possible, and then have price
push or continue in the direction that
they're expecting it to go for today.
Again, June 2nd, 2025, using the power
of 50 from both previous days 50 and
London 50. We can see that price broke
out of London 50 after a continuation
over previous days 50 and just continued
to fly. We had a $4 opening candle on
Q's that correlated to 134 points on MNQ
or NQ. I believe it peaked at about 160
points and then we had a 120 point
pullback.
That pullback is going to stop most
people out, myself included, because I
made the mistake of trying to get in
before the ret the retest
happened. You always wait for that
retest. In this case, my trading model
is using the power of 50 London combined
with previous days 50, otherwise known
as equilibrium. Shout out to
Trades. For the power of 50, I always,
always, always wait for a retest. The
reason that I didn't wait today was
because we broke out of London high and
at the time price was showing very
strong volume coming in. Honestly, I
could explain as much as I want to. It
was a loss. Simple as that. I broke my
rules. I lost. So, what I did to correct
that, wait for the retest. In this case,
we retested back down. As I said, 120
point candle down on NQ. We hit the
power of 50 London. Wicked off of it.
That was my entry. My stop loss was a
15-minute candle closed below the 50 and
the 50 from previous day. What happened
after price reacted at that level? We
had a beautiful continuation up and now
we are at previous days high which is
the price target after you hit previous
day's 50 or for London session. After
you hit London 50, you look for London
high. Both targets hit. This was a
beautiful 200 point continuation to the
upside. Excuse me. That retest is your
entry. Now, stick to the 15-minut time
frame or stick to the 5minut time frame,
1 hour time frame, whatever it might be,
whatever your trading model is, stick to
that time frame and wait for the retest.
Now, there is a method that you can do
uh it's on the one minute time frame. Go
down to the one minute and this is how I
discovered the strategy was looking at
the one minute time frame. Hopefully, it
happens real time here. The one minute
time frame back tested by myself
personally has about a 75% chance that
whatever wick forms first and we're
seeing it happen right now. Initial wick
up typically sees a pivot to the
downside. Exactly what we're looking at
right now. That's awesome. So, you have
an initial wick that forms. In this
case, we just opened at
455, pivoted up to 457, and now we're
having that pivot back down to
447. This is on the one minute time
frame. Whatever the initial wick is, you
typically fall or push the opposite way
of that wick. In this case, we wicked
up, so we're having that push back down.
If we have a wick down, you have that
push back up. I'll wait for another 15
minute uh not another 15-minute candle,
another one minute candle to open here
just to kind of prove my point. But this
is where I I realized, hey, price
typically retraces whatever the initial
wick of a candle is. Now, this is the
same case for an hour candle. This is
the same case for a 15-minute, 5 minute,
4 hour, daily candle, whatever it might
be, monthly candle even. In this case,
we're getting an initial wick down. Now
we should see price start to push up,
which it is not all that aggressive on
this candle, but you can see the concept
working. You typically have a
retracement. Uh just so you don't think
I'm pivoting off the candle because it
was pushing down. It's still working out
a little bit. That's where the concept
came from. And then I started realizing,
and this is the same thing that uh
Trades post, Leo Invest post, both the
guys that I prefer to work with or uh
review trades from. Whatever time frame
you're
using, the candle typically wicks the
opposite direction and then pushes
whatever direction it was meant to go.
So in this case uh looking at today's
4hour open we had a wick down and we can
see that it was present on the 5m minute
we had a wick down to open the first 30
minutes of this candle were a wick down
and then we had that massive
continuation up that was on the hourly
time frame now let's go to the 4our we
can see same thing on Friday same thing
back here on Wednesday Thursday Friday
whatever time frame you're looking at
you typically wick in the opposing
direction. Now, that should be your
entry. Again, depending on whatever your
entry model might be, you're waiting for
that retest. You're waiting for that
wick of the next candle to form and then
you can play the continuation after
that.
Now, I've made many, many mistakes
entering trades as soon as I expected
the breakout, and today is a perfect
example of why that is just not the
right thing to do. going down to the 15
minute again. I still make these
mistakes. I chased this candle up and I
got burnt on the following candle
because of it. But then I made the
correction. My entry model formed. We
got a retrace back down to the 50 and
then I capitalize on that expansion all
the way back up to previous day's high.
Learn from me. Learn from the mistakes
that I've made. Learn to be patient
enough to wait for that wick to form.
wait for the retest and then play the
continuation. Doesn't matter what chart
you're looking at. All the candles are
the same. The only thing that changes is
the ticker name and the time frame.
That's it. If you're on the one minute,
wait a few seconds for that wick to
form. If you're on the 3 minute, wait 10
to 15 seconds. Five minute time frame,
wait 20 seconds. 15 minute, wait a
minute. Hourly, wait five minutes. 4
hour, wait 15 minutes. and the 24-hour
time frame. Wait about an hour to two
hours and that wick will form. You
typically proceed in the opposing
direction. I'll pull this up one more
time on the one minute time
frame. Let's watch one more candle form
before we end the video just to put some
icing on top. So, this next candle's
forming. Initial wick down. I don't know
if you caught that. Now we're having a
little pivot to the upside
ultimately forming a dogee candle at the
moment. This is real time by the way.
This is not recorded afterwards. There's
our initial wick down and as you can see
we're getting a continuation back to the
upside. There you go. Have a great one.
See you guys next week for another
video.